[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et nous accueillons cette
semaine violette spielboot bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
députés renaissance du Nord et
porte-parole du groupe majoritaire
beaucoup d'actualité pour vous et cette
semaine on va parler de l'agenda
parlementaire d'ici à l'été qui commence
à se préciser une série de réformes qui
a un objectif pour le gouvernement
tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites alors que la mobilisation se
poursuit dans la rue et face aux
violences dans les manifestations la
majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
nationale souhaite une commission
d'enquête sur les casseurs les députés
insoumis dénoncent initiative qui
détournent le regard des violences
policières et puis le Sénat va aussi
ouvrir une nouvelle commission d'enquête
dont le viseur des sénateurs le font
Marianne en font gouvernemental lancé en
2021 par Marine Schiappa pour lutter
contre la radicalisation en ligne mais
l'argent de ce fond aurait été mal
utilisé notamment à des fins politiques
le parquet national financier ouvert
jeudi une information judiciaire pour
détournement de fonds publics
on commence par cette question quelle
marge de manœuvre le gouvernement a-t-il
au Parlement après la réforme des
retraites qui a accaparé député ses
sénateurs plusieurs textes sont d'ores
et déjà à l'ordre du jour jusqu'à la
mi-juillet budget des jardins emploie ou
encore RSA le deux tailles du menu
parlementaire avec Elsa mondingue à
la semaine prochaine en commission les
députés examineront la loi de
programmation militaire 413 milliards
d'euros de dépenses entre 2024 et 2030
un objectif ambitieux transformer les
armées françaises autre projet de loi
présenté à la mi-mai celui sur
l'industrie verte faciliter les
ouvertures d'usine tout en poussant à la
décarbonation de l'industrie examen
prévus à l'été le gouvernement souhaite
par ailleurs mettre à l'ordre du jour
rapidement la loi sur le partage de la
valeur une transposition de l'accord
entre patronat et syndicats pour
généraliser les dispositifs comme
l'intéressement la participation ou
encore l'actionnariat salarié à toutes
les entreprises de plus de 11 personnes
un texte plein emploi est également
prévu d'ici le mois de juin Pôle Emploi
deviendra France travail pour inciter au
retour à l'emploi le RSA le revenu de
solidarité active sera conditionnée à
une quinzaine d'heures d'activités par
semaine
une mesure d'ores et déjà très critiquée
le gouvernement travaillant enfin un
texte plus large sur le travail qui
pourrait réintégrer les mesures de la
réforme des retraites censurées par le
Conseil constitutionnel comme l'index
senior le projet de loi immigration et
lui reporté à l'automne le temps
d'essayer de dégager une majorité avec
la droite notamment
est-ce que vous pensez violette
spielboot que cet agenda parlementaire
est de nature à apaiser le pays alors
que la mobilisation dans la rue se
poursuit contre la réforme contre pour
la réforme des retraites et contre la
réforme des retraites excusez-moi avec
une majorité de Français la soutient
est-ce que c'est le bon agenda et le bon
moment pour ça alors c'est un agenda qui
pour moi politiquement effectivement va
apaiser les choses parce qu'il va se
concentrer sur des grandes priorités
pour les Français je pense vous parliez
tout à l'heure de de la loi sur la
décarbonation de l'industrie c'est un
vrai enjeu d'urgence écologique de
transition écologique ça par exemple
c'est quelque chose de très rassembleur
qui va mobiliser à la fois les chefs
d'entreprise les employés les jeunes
tous ceux qui veulent que on ait une
économie demain moins polluante et donc
ça va être un projet passionnant après
le fait
que c'est des textes qui sont attendus
et je vous entends c'est celui de
l'immigration parce que c'est vrai que
l'immigration doit traiter ce sujet là
sur ces deux volets le fait qu'il y ait
eu le report à la rentrée ça c'est un
signe pour moi d'apaisement ça veut dire
que on a besoin quand même puisqu'on
doit accélérer sur beaucoup de réformes
de trois mois là jusqu'à l'été où on va
pouvoir travailler vite et bien parce
que nous au niveau du Parlement quand on
voit tous ces projets de loi on sait
qu'on va accélérer on vous avait parlé
de beaucoup de projets de loi notamment
sur le travail sur le RSA mais il y a
aussi le numérique les influenceurs il y
a aussi
la loi que sur le partage de la valeur
qui va nous mobiliser fortement enfin
voilà il y a beaucoup de sujets sur
lequel on va devoir être efficace on
parlera notamment du RSA et
l'immigration mais d'abord une question
sur la réforme des retraites on est
toujours dans une séquence de
mobilisation sociale assez forte contre
ce texte et cette semaine et bien la
deuxième demande de référendum
initiative partagée sur la réforme des
retraites a été rejetée par le Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que quand même et
bien donner la voix au peuple demander
la vie aux français n'aurait pas été une
solution pour sortir de cette crise
sociale
je crois que nous oppositions
ont tenté l'ensemble des voix
démocratiques institutionnelles pour
contester cette réforme on a passé
plusieurs étapes le vote à l'assemblée
au Sénat le 49-3 le recours devant le
Conseil constitutionnel les propositions
de référendum aujourd'hui c'est rejeté
donc nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est
continuer de travailler sur tous les
sujets qui ont été soulevés pendant la
réforme des retraites et justement les
trois étapes des lois sur le travail
vont aborder les conditions de vie au
travail la qualité de vie au travail la
pénibilité l'égalité homme et femme ça
c'est des sujets qu'on abandonne pas et
qui vont nous occuper tout au long de
l'année 2023 mais en attendant contre
cette réforme des retraites il y a une
initiative le 8 juin à l'Assemblée
nationale une proposition loi du groupe
liotte les députés du territoire pour
abroger uniquement l'article qui fait
passer l'âge de la retraite de 62 à 64
ans est-ce que si cette proposition de
loi était adoptée Emmanuel Macron
devrait alors renoncer à appliquer sa
réforme si cette proposition de loi
était adoptée le 8 juin elle serait
adoptée à l'Assemblée elle passerait
ensuite au Sénat c'est à dire que on
rentrerait dans un cycle parlementaire
nouveau moi j'espère qu'elle ne sera pas
adoptée parce que on a une conscience
une responsabilité sur l'enjeu qui est
l'équilibre de nos systèmes de retraite
et sa préservation pour l'avenir de nos
enfants après nous on va être très mais
nous non plus on l'achète pas on va être
très très mobilisé le 8 juin c'est un
moment important effectivement on a eu
15 jours de pause dans l'hémicie qui
nous a permis d'être dans nos
circonscriptions au contact des Français
on voit qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
sujets que les retraites qui n'est
préoccupent on y reviendra dans votre
émission mais le 8 juin nous serons au
complet au groupe Renaissance horizon et
modem j'en suis sûr mais quand même
démocratiquement en cas de rejet par
l'Assemblée nationale de cette réforme
de retraite est-ce que ce serait un coup
dur et ce qu'il faudrait renoncer à
appliquer ce texte
même si le sénatienne une forme
d'humilité quand même au regard de la
situation politique on est aujourd'hui
en majorité relative ça veut
effectivement dire que rien n'est simple
que les voix des oppositions sont fortes
on le voit très régulièrement en compte
il y a d'ailleurs beaucoup de projets de
loi finalement dans ces échanges un peu
brutaux parfois avec l'opposition qui
évolue en terme de contenu en termes de
coût en termes de financement tout ça ça
montre que les voix des Français sont
représentées à l'Assemblée nationale et
justement jeudi en une seule journée et
bien les députés d'opposition ont réussi
à faire voter une proposition de loi qui
abroge l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants contre le covid et une autre
proposition de loi sur EDF qui élargie
le bouclier tarifaire sur l'électricité
aux artisans ou PME à certaines
collectivités territoriales cela fait
une dépense supplémentaire de 11
milliards d'euros voté contre la vie du
gouvernement et de la majorité
présidentielle une sorte de victoire
pour les oppositions on va écouter le
député communiste Sébastien Jumel
les boulangers sont dans le pétrin et
les boulangers comme les artisans comme
les PME comme les toutes petites
entreprises sont confrontées à
l'explosion du prix de l'énergie qui
fragilise leur existence qui fragilisent
leur compétitivité pour ce qui concerne
nos industries nos PME au TPE et qui
justifient que nous puissions n'ont pas
ouvrir la boîte de Pandore de la dépense
publique pour être à leurs chevets mais
d'être efficace violette spield
spielboot finalement c'est 100 jours à
l'Assemblée commence par une défaite
politique pour le gouvernement et la
majorité
c'est ce vote hier pour moi il est
plutôt symbolique d'une victoire d'une
alliance entre la nups et le
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
donc effectivement sur le plan
symbolique c'est pas une victoire après
sur le plan politique
restant en raisonnable on voit bien que
l'engagement du président de la
République du gouvernement c'est d'avoir
100% des actions d'EDF c'est de protéger
EDF et d'en faire le leader mondial de
l'énergie que ce soit de sa production
de sa distribution et de la fourniture
ça veut dire aussi une décarbonation une
nouvelle programmation nucléaire tout ça
c'est des ambitions très fortes nous on
veut que EDF aille vite et puis se
transformer finalement ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui il a très peu parlé de la
transformation de déesse c'était un peu
la bonne excuse pour évoquer plein
d'autres sujets sur lesquels il y avait
des propositions un peu démagogiques de
l'ensemble de nos oppositions donc il
fait la navette il a déjà fait le Sénat
l'Assemblée va repartir en deuxième
lecture on voit aussi que c'est une
dépense publique de 11 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires alors au profit des PME
des collectés
qui souffrent parfois terriblement de
l'inflation vous savez moi sur ma
circonscription j'ai été beaucoup
sollicité depuis Noël sur les sujets
énergétiques que ce soit dans le Nord à
Lille sur des petites donc des TPE des
boulangeries des artisans mais aussi sur
des PME une imprimerie dans ma
circonscription à Bondues avec des
factures qui explosaient et bien moi je
l'ai vu et l'ensemble de mes collègues
députés à chaque fois qu'il y avait une
situation particulière sur un contrat
qui avait été signé pour 24 mois au pire
moment du prix de l'électricité et bien
cette situation elle a été prise en
compte à la fois par l'État par des
aides spécifiques et aussi par des
fournisseurs d'énergie qui ont été
poussés à faire des efforts particuliers
et d'ailleurs Roland Lescure la redit
hier dans l'hémicycle monsieur jumelles
si vous avez une facture qui a explosé
d'une PME envoyez-la moi et nous allons
nous en occuper donc nous on croit au
bouclier aux aides mais 11 milliards
d'euros de façon générale pour étendre
le tarif réglementé quand on voit la
situation des finances publiques c'est
un vrai sujet alors dans cet agenda
parlementaire le gouvernement présentera
en jouant un projet de loi pour le plein
emploi un texte qui va notamment
conditionner le RSA à 15 à 20h
d'activités par semaine et que vous
croyez que cette mesure dans le contexte
social que l'on connaît et bien ça va
pas ça ne va pas tendre encore plus les
choses
c'est une mesure sensible mais c'est une
mesure indispensable aujourd'hui parce
que nous ce qu'on veut c'est que chaque
personne qui bénéficie du RSA 700 800
euros par mois puisse bénéficier d'un
réel accompagnement ça veut dire des
moyens humains en plus des moyens
financiers en plus de l'état de France
du futur trans travail pour accompagner
à une réinsertion à l'emploi bien sûr
une femme qui vit seule avec trois
enfants en bas âge ne peut pas
effectivement faire 15 heures 20 heures
d'activité là-dessus le ministre a été
clair il y aura des situations
exceptionnelles qui auront et qui seront
prises en compte mais en fait le
principe quand même c'est de donner à
chacun la chance d'être accompagné ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui on a
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des
bénéficiaires du RSA qui ne sont pas
inscrits à Pôle emploi qui ne sont pas
suivis par un coach comme nous on l'a
par exemple dans l'expérimentation qui
est faite par le département du Nord en
ce moment et qui est très efficace c'est
à dire il y a des coachs emploi qui sont
là c'est aider à pouvoir passer le
permis de conduire par exemple à
maîtriser le français à l'écrit des
choses toutes simples qui vont permettre
de remettre le pied à l'étrier après une
période difficile dans la vie très
rapidement une dernière question sur le
projet de loi immigration qui a été
plusieurs fois reportée a priori c'est
pour septembre est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose pour vous de remettre ce
sujet alors du jour alors qu'on sait que
c'est tabou et que ça risque peut-être
de vous diviser vous la majorité je ne
pense pas que ce soit un sujet tabou
parce que dans la bouche et la tête des
Français je vous dis que le sujet
immigration il revient très souvent à la
fois les Français sont très préoccupés
par les délinquants qui ne sont pas
suffisamment l'objet de qtf qui sont
réalisés c'est-à-dire le l'obligation de
quitter le territoire et de retourner
dans leur pays d'origine et puis à la
fois toutes nos entrepreneurs sont très
préoccupés de toutes les personnes qui
sont d'origine étrangère qui n'ont pas
le permis de travailler aujourd'hui en
France et qui pourtant ont déjà fait un
stage un apprentissage correspondent
exactement à la compétence dont ils ont
besoin dans la climatisation
l'électricité la maintenance des
bâtiments par exemple ou la restauration
et qui ne pas embauché parce qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas ils le droit donc aujourd'hui
il y a vraiment des situations très très
concrètes à résoudre et c'est très
important pour nous dans les hauts de
France on a par exemple le canal senor
qui est un grand projet d'aménagement
c'est 8000 emplois à horizon 10 ans
qu'on va devoir pourvoir sur les travaux
publics on verra tout ça en attendant
parlons de cette commission d'enquête
qui vise à faire la lumière sur les
violences commises lors des
manifestations récentes contre la
réforme des retraites ou encore le
projet de méga bassine à Sainte Soline
c'est une demande du groupe Renaissance
ce mercredi les députés en ont validé de
principe écoutez les explications du
rapporteur et la réponse de l'opposition
nous visons des individus organisés qui
armés
viennent pour en découdre avec les
forces de l'ordre c'est très clair nous
ne disons pas les organisations
syndicales nous disons même pas les
formations politiques même quand nous
considérons que certaines d'entre elles
ne dénoncent pas assez fort la
Commission des violences il faut
comprendre d'où vient cette cette
violence aujourd'hui et cette finalement
parfois radicalisation d'un certain
nombre de groupes et d'actions elle
vient aussi du fait que notre pacte
démocratique ne va pas bien pardon mais
c'est pas une commission d'enquête qu'il
faudrait s'échanger de ministre de
l'Intérieur en l'occurrence
violette spipoutes est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le fait que cette
commission d'enquête vise uniquement les
violences des casseurs et non pas les
violences de certains policiers qui
existent aussi pour vous le chant de la
Commission et mais bon faut pas se
voiler la face quand même vu ce qu'on a
vu pendant les manifestations contre les
retraites pendant Sainte-Souline
effectivement il y a quand même un vrai
sujet qui est l'influence et
l'implication de l'ultra gauche des
casseurs dans la violence dans les
manifestations et le fait que notre
majorité donc Aurore berger notre
présidente de groupe et Laurent Marco
Angeli le président du groupe horizon
souhaite cette commission d'enquête
c'est une chose absolument nécessaire et
que les Français veulent on ne veut plus
décaisseurs dans notre manifestation il
faut trouver des solutions après moi
j'ai échangé avec Florent Boudier
puisque c'est passé en commission hier
et que c'est lui qui va être rapporteur
dans cette commission d'enquête lui a
tenu effectivement à entendre nos
oppositions et à ce que à l'occasion de
cette commission d'enquête on puisse
aussi avoir la lumière sur l'ensemble
des violences on a eu un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale mardi d'ailleurs
dans le cadre de la Semaine de contrôle
et moi je suis aussi intervenu sur ce
sujet y compris on souhaite que la
lumière et la transparence soit faite
sur l'ensemble des violences bien sûr
les proportions ne sont pas les mêmes on
a une soixantaine d'enquêtes aujourd'hui
administratives et pénale contre des
policiers qui auraient commis des
débordements et bien il faut que ces
enquêtes soient suivies que le Parlement
est connaissance de l'ensemble de
l'efficacité de tout ce qui est fait
dans ce cadre là mais notre cible
principale ça reste comment ces
groupuscules sont structurés financés
pour infiltrer nos manifestations
aujourd'hui à l'extérieur comme au
premier mai devant le cortège à
l'arrière du cortège mais demain nous ne
voulons pas que ce soit à l'intérieur
alors Gérard de Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur travaille sur une nouvelle
loi anti-casseur violette spielboot
est-ce que ce serait une bonne idée de
remettre sur la table cette mesure
d'interdiction administrative de
manifester pour certaines personnes
c'est assez compliqué juridiquement et
constitutionnellement il y a déjà une
loi anti-casseurs qui existent je crois
que le ministre de la Justice le
ministre de l'Intérieur se voit ce
vendredi et vont travailler dans les
jours à venir pour voir si il faut mieux
renforcer l'application de la loi
anti-casseurs aujourd'hui ou avoir des
mesures législatives supplémentaires la
question du contrôle a priori avant les
manifestations normalement ce sont la
confiscation des armes par exemple ou
l'identité de certaines personnes qui
seraient fichaient peut se poser parce
finalement les Français qui nous
interpellent ils nous disent bah
pourquoi vous les empêchez pas de venir
dans les manifestations c'est facile
dans un lieu fermé dans un stade où on
peut avoir des contrôles c'est facile
aussi parce que la loi le permet dans
les manifestations interdites de faire
des contrôles à priori comme c'était le
cas à Sainte Soline et des confiscations
d'armes en revanche sur une
manifestation autorisée aujourd'hui la
Constitution ne le permet pas donc
leur méthode change il cache les armes
avant ils viennent trois quatre jours
avant tout tous ces casseurs ont des
ressorts très nouveau le digital etc il
faut que nous on s'adapte on a déjà
expérimenté les drones le 1er mai dans
beaucoup de lieux de manifestations en
France ça a évité un incendie grave à la
mairie de Lyon c'est donc efficace sur
beaucoup de situations il va falloir
qu'on continue de s'adapter et c'est
là-dessus que les deux ministres
travaillent aujourd'hui alors la
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté a publié un rapport
qui critique des garde à vue abusives
dans les manifs 80% de Gard on a vu son
relâchés sans poursuites selon elle et
ce qu'on arrête des manifestants sans
motif sérieux pour vous vous savez quand
on regarde la tenue de ces
manifestations on voit bien que il y a
des mouvements de foule très important
des fumigènes des charges très fortes
contre les policiers d'ailleurs le
sénateur socialiste qui a passé une
journée avec la braven la constaté redit
lui-même donc effectivement il y a des
actions rapides des arrestations rapides
et sont suites c'est au rôle du
procureur de la police de faire leur
travail et de faire le tri entre des
suites pénales qui doivent être donnés
ou des personnes qui sont relâchées
c'est pas à nous de commenter des
décisions de justice moi je crois pour
avoir discuté avec beaucoup de policiers
nationaux en particulier à Lille où
c'était un petit peu plus calme et à
Paris ces derniers jours que il y a une
vraie conscience déontologique de
l'ensemble de la profession de
conscience du risque aussi de cette
provocation permanente des casseurs eux
ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'il y ait
quelque chose encore plus grave
aujourd'hui ce qui est le plus grave
c'est ce policier brûlé par cocktail
Molotov c'est les policiers qui sont
victimes c'est ça la réalité rapidement
est-ce que vous diriez que la justice
d'ailleurs comme le dit le président du
groupe LR au Sénat Bruno retaillod
est-ce que la justice dans ses affaires
de violences dans les manifestations
est-ce que la justice est un peu laxiste
je crois que la justice est en train de
se transformer jour après jour et
d'ailleurs on en a pas parlé tout à
l'heure en début d'émission mais il y a
aussi un projet de vol justice que porte
Éric Dupond-Moretti il travaille avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur spécifiquement
sur ce sujet des casseurs va falloir
qu'on soit très efficace et va falloir
aussi que on s'adapte à toutes ces
nouvelles techniques et à ces
regroupements européens par exemple on
en a discuté avec Gérald Darmanin il y a
des actions aussi au niveau des autres
pays avec les autres pays européens pour
faire en sorte que c'est rassemblements
et ses infiltrations dans nos
manifestations en France ne soient plus
possible alors le Sénat va aussi lancer
une commission d'enquête une commission
d'enquête sur le fond Marianne un fonds
gouvernemental créé en 2021 par Marlène
Schiappa après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty un fond pour lutter contre la
radicalisation en ligne mais le problème
c'est que l'argent ne se font Marianne
aurait été mal utilisé par les
associations qui en ont bénéficié
notamment pour certaines à des fins
politiques le parquet national financier
a ouvert jeudi une information
judiciaire pour détournement de fonds
publics Cécile Sixou
ils l'ont demandé elle sera créée les
sénateurs de la commission des finances
mèneront bien une commission d'enquête
sur le fond Marianne jean-François a eu
son en sera le rapporteur nous avons
besoin de comprendre de quelle manière à
l'issue d'un événement dramatique je le
rappelle l'assassinat barbare de Samuel
Paty le gouvernement par la voix d'une
ministre avait pris des décisions créant
un fond Marianne aujourd'hui certaines
informations ont été rendues publiques
et notamment sur l'utilisation de ces
fonds au total 2,5 millions d'euros
avaient été alloués à 17 associations
pour promouvoir les valeurs de la
République mais selon une enquête
conjointe du magazine Marianne et de
France 2 une des associations qui a
touché
355000 euros aurait écrit un site
hilaïque très peu suivi une autre
structure dotée de 330 000 euros aurait
dénigré plusieurs personnalités
politiques tout au fait
comment dire en contre discours
républicain et que l'on veut intéresser
les jeunes à la République on commence
pas par critiquer ses élus voilà tout
simplement donc il y a là déjà un
premier sujet et sur la nature des
contenus et des attaques qui ont été
proférées je crois qu'il a aussi il y a
beaucoup à dire alors des remarques ont
été faites par les gestionnaires de ce
fond mais sans conséquence semble-t-il
puisque l'ensemble des financements ont
été versés et qu'on n'a pas vu
réellement de changement dans l'attitude
de cette association la commission
d'enquête devra déterminer si Marlène
Schiappa à l'origine de la création de
ce fond a joué un rôle dans son
attribution aux associations la
secrétaire d'État promet qu'elle
répondra ont toute transparence et ni
tout favoritisme j'ai pas choisi les
associations et je veux démentir aussi
quelque chose qui a été dit notamment
par certains responsables et les filles
qui ont dit que j'avais donné d'argent à
mes amis qui avaient du copinage ou du
favoritisme je ne suis amie avec aucun
lauréat du fond Marianne aucun pas un
pas un est mon proche ni personnellement
associer ni que sais-je contrairement à
ce que j'ai lu eux-mêmes l'ont démenti
mais après vous voyez à quel point ces
accusations sont difficiles à démentir
la commission d'enquête commencera ses
auditions fin mai elle a trois mois
ensuite pour rendre aussi conclusions
violet spielboot avec cette affaire du
fond Marianne est-ce que vous craignez
qu'on se dirige vers un scandale d'État
moi je crois que ce qui se passe sur ce
fond Marianne est très simple on a deux
démarches parallèles une démarche au
Sénat qui vient d'être votée à
l'unanimité qui est une commission
d'enquête qui va faire la transparence
sur l'attribution des fonds moi je pense
que c'est très important pour les
français en général quand on a voté la
semaine prochaine ils voteront
avec les moyens d'enquête pourquoi parce
que quand il y a des subventions quand
il y a un jury quand il y a des critères
d'attribution qui est plus de
transparence c'est une nécessité il y a
beaucoup d'argent public et distribué
aux associations et c'est ce que l'on
doit aux Français et puis il y a une
deuxième démarche qui la démarche
juridique celle du parquet national
financier faut peut-être pas oublier de
dire que qui a suscité cette enquête
c'est quelque part le ministre de
l'Intérieur puisqu'il y a une
association qui a signalé un
dysfonctionnement au ministère de
l'Intérieur et c'est donc le ministère
de l'Intérieur qui sur le fondement de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
à lancer cette cette plainte et pour
qu'il y ait une enquête donc les choses
se font normalement on a une ministre
qui s'est à la fois expliqué et qui
porte plainte pour diffamation je pense
que on doit réaffirmer notre souci de
transparence notre lutte aussi contre
les fake news voilà et on ne peut pas
présumer de la conclusion à la fois de
la commission au Sénat et de l'enquête
du PNF alors on verra ce que ce que ce
que diront
l'enquête on verra ce que dira l'enquête
mais est-ce que vous trouvez tout de
même que Marlène sciaba est dans une
position confortable pour exercer
sereinement ses fonctions au sein du
gouvernement Marlène siapas c'est c'est
très clairement exprimé déjà sur ce
sujet je pense que le président de la
commission des finances au Sénat à
lui-même indiqué que elle n'était pas
visée personnellement le sujet c'est de
faire la lumière sur la façon dont sont
attribués des subventions par l'État à
des associations c'est sain je le redis
et attendant la conclusion des enquêtes
le président de cette commission
d'enquête au Sénat et Claude renard un
sénateur socialiste est-ce que vous
craignez une nouvelle affaire Benalla
c'est à dire que et bien les oppositions
tendent un peu déstabiliser le
gouvernement avec cette enquête
parlementaire non moi je crois en la
probité de l'ensemble des élus de la
République on parlait tout à l'heure du
sénateur socialiste qui était au sein de
la Bravet mais qui reconnaissait avec
beaucoup de clarté le travail que
faisait les policiers sans jugement
partisan quelque part je crois que quand
on est président d'une commission
d'enquête on fait sérieusement son
travail on doit ça tous aux français
qu'on soit socialistes qu'on soit de la
majorité présidentielle qu'on soit des
républicains ou des autres partis on a
tous la responsabilité que les Français
nous fassent confiance pour l'intérêt
général pour la transparence pour la
bonne gestion des fonds publics moi
c'est ça qui m'importe et bien on va
finir par un coup d'oeil à l'agenda de
la semaine prochaine au Parlement
[Musique]
et mardi les sénateurs des patrons d'une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
les dérives des influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux mercredi ils examineront
une proposition de loi qui vise à
faciliter le passage et l'obtention du
permis de conduire et à l'Assemblée
mardi 9 mai une proposition de
résolution pour un inscrire le groupe
Wagner les mercenaires suspectés d'agir
dans l'ombre de Poutine sur la liste des
organisations terroristes et puis une
proposition de loi pour rendre
obligatoire le pavoisement des drapeaux
français et européens sur le fronton des
mairies en quelques secondes justement
sur cette proposition de rendre
obligatoire les drapeaux français
européens sur les mairies elle a été
rejetée en commission c'est à dire que
la majorité présidentielle est divisée
sur ce point
aux j'en ai parlé hier avec le président
du groupe modem on est resté tard
ensemble à l'Assemblée
moi je pense que cette proposition sera
votée parce que beaucoup de maires le
font déjà aujourd'hui en fait se sentent
responsables à la fois d'afficher nos
valeurs européennes et nos valeurs de la
République française ça nous semble
important symboliquement le 9 mai le
jour de la fête de l'Europe que cette
proposition soit votée et moi je reste
confiance et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup violette
spielboot d'avoir été notre invité cette
semaine et merci à tous d'avoir suivi
cette émission et rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine ciao ciao
[Musique]